this video is about the
explorative factor analysis and the
best thing is i explain everything very slowly
and simply and with that we start
right away what is the explorative
factor analysis in the explorative factors
this is a procedure
that has pubs it structures on it  to discover in data
is a data set with a
lot of variables so it may be
that some of them are related, i.e.
coalesce with each other
these connections are the basis
of factor analysis the task of
factor analysis is now
to divide the variables into groups the
most
If
each factor analysis is related or correlated, it is therefore
to divide variables into groups. The
variables that correlate should not be separated
from those that
correlate less strongly.
Within the groups, the
variables should correlate as highly as possible,
but as little as possible between the groups.
But what does a factor mean?
in factor analysis, the factor can be viewed
as a hidden
variable affecting several actually
observed variables, so
here we have our observed
variables and we have behind them the
factors affecting those
variables, or in other words, multiple
variables are
observable phenomena of fewer underlying
factors
a short  summary of what
we know so far in the factor analysis
, the variables that
correlate highly with one another are combined with one another.
it is assumed that this
correlation comes about through an immeasurable
variable which
is
now called a factor
summarize personality traits such as sociability curious sociable or helpful to personality types such as conscientious extrovert agreeable
to find out do you have a
kle  a survey created with data tab server
you now want to find out if some of
the traits are highly
correlated and
can be described by a factor so you
want to find out if some of the
traits sociable sociable hardworking
dutiful warmhearted or
helpful are correlated and
thereby described by an underlying
factor  20 people can be
interviewed first and the
result displayed in an excel spreadsheet
you can
find the link to the excel document
in the video description
now a little anticipation at the end of the
factor analysis we could then come to the
conclusion that
sociable and sociable through  the
extraversion factor can be described as
hardworking and dutiful by
conscientiousness and
warm and helpful by
agreeableness
but how we arrive at this result
we will now go through step by step
in the first step we calculate  we use the
factor analysis for this
example and then i
will use the results to explain the procedure of the
factor analysis
to calculate the factor
analysis we use datatec the link is
in the video description first
we click on the statistics calculator
and then we run our  data in
this table 1 for this
just click learn on the wave and
copy our own data into the
table
now we have pasted our data into the
table and we click on
this tab pca
then here below we see the six
variables that we have we want  calculate the
factor analysis for all six
variables so let's just click on
all six variables
sociability sociable hardworking
dutiful framework cordial and
helpful
so now we have to
choose the number of factors first
let's just assume the number of factors with
three how to get there  I'll explain them to
you
later first  If you now look at the correlation
smart rix in the coalition matrix,
you can see how strongly or how little the
properties
coalesce with each other, e.g. sociable coalesces with sociable
very strongly, but sociable and
workspace do not correlate too strongly
with one another, with the help of the correlation
matrix you get an overview of
which ones  properties that correlate strongly and
which correlate less strongly with each
other, the coalition
matrix is ​​the basis for calculating the so-called
own values ​​and own vectors
, but we will come to that later,
we have six variables, so
we can have a maximum of six factors in
this table are the factors of
size  sorted by the first factor is
the one that explains the most variance and the
last one that explains the least variance
so the first factor can
explain 31 21 percent of the total variance of the
six variables the second
factor alone can explain 24.7 percent of the
total variance of the six
factors  laren and finally the last
factor alone can only explain 3.44 percent of the
total variance on the
far right we can still see the cumulative
percent if we take the first two
factors together we can
use the first two
factors alone to account for 55.9 percent of the total variance of the
elucidate six variables and if we take
the first three
factors we can already elucidate 78.6 2 percent of the entire
choice that's
quite a lot so if we can take these first three factors instead of
the six original variables
we can elucidate
78.6 2%  explain the original
variant but now the question arises how
many factors do I really need
to this question the factor
analysis does not give a clear answer but
there are two methods to determine the number of required factors
these we will now briefly go through how many factors are required
i for both
methods the own values ​​are
sorted by size and in a
we have entered the number of factors 1 to 6 on the x-axis
and we have our own values ​​on the y-axis
we start with the eigenvalue criterion
for the eigenvalue criterion you simply look at
how many of your own values ​​are greater
than one that results  the number of
factors in this case are two
factors greater than 1
accordingly in this case the number of factors would be
2 the scui test is a
graphical method here it is simply
read in the diagram pub before there is a path
or a so-called
elbow that would also be  exactly at this
point, accordingly,
the number of factors would also
come out with two with this method, but in practice, of course
, this diagram does not
always look so nice let's just take a look at
the diagram of our
example in our if you see the
diagram like this  Of course we can't see
any kinks here and we
would simply go the way of our own
values  we look at how many
factors have an intrinsic value of the course
11 and now we take the number
of factors in this case we have
three factors that have a value
greater than 1 so we take the number
as three years the number of
factors can now be determined  the
municipal actions are calculated the
municipal actions indicate how much
variance of the variable can be explained by the three
selected factors
, for example,
77 percent of the variance
can be explained by the variable sociableness purely by the three
factors, or
88 percent of the variance by the variable sociability
be explained purely by the three
selected factors now we have
heard three terms again and again factor
charge intrinsic value and criminality
I would now like to briefly explain these using the example
throughout the factor charge indicates, for example,
how high the correlation is between
sociable and extraversion is an
intrinsic value, for example  to how much
variance by the fact  or
conscientiousness
can be explained by all variables and the communal
activity indicates how much variance of the six
variables can be explained by the three
factors now i
cheated a bit we
haven't actually reached this
nice result yet so that we have this nice
result  so
to be able to assign a factor exactly to the variables we
need two more steps and e commerce
next we have the component
matrix output the component matrix
gives us the loading of the factors
on the variables here the first
factor is the second factor and the third
factor we can read here, for example,
that the first factor coalesces with the
variable sociable at 0.67
or that the first factor coalesces with
the variable sociable at 0.8
because the first factor explains the most variance
, the values ​​of the first
factor are the greatest
Of course, that's not exactly ideal because
we were actually the only ones  Divide
variables into the three factors
and don't want to
bundle a lot of variables into one factor.
Actually, we want to assign the variables to
the factors and thus
form groups. In this case, however, a
lot of variables would be assigned to the first
factor, so this can
component matrix usually cannot be
meaningfully interpreted and we
still need one last step the
so-called rotation sex
there are various methods for rotation, but the
most common is the analytical one
such as max rotation using the scale max
rotation should be analytically
ensured that per factor  load certain variables
as high as possible and load the other variables
as low as possible this result
is obtained when the variance of the factor
load per factor is as high as possible in
the table above you can now
see that sociable and
sociable can be assigned to the first factor work
space
and dutiful have  n the
greatest values ​​with the factor 3 so
can be assigned the factor 3
and warm-hearted and helpful have the
greatest values ​​with the factor 2 so
can be assigned the factor 2
as we now call
the factors the factor analysis does not tell us that is the
task of  researchers naming these
i have used a simplified form of the
well known big five personal
thies here and so it is
easy to name the factors here too
we could
describe
e.g
with the
factor
compatibility we have now assigned the six
original properties to the
three factors
now let's go
through the whole thing again quickly to repeat it
so in the first step we
simply copied our data into the table
then we clicked on the tab pca  got
and you  e number of factors selected
the first thing we got from was
the correlation smart rix the
correlation smart tricks gives us an
overview of how the different
properties correlate from the
correlation smart tricks could then
calculate its own values ​​and vectors and we could look at the
table with explained total variance
house then
we could then use the eigenvalue criterion to determine the
number of
factors here we got three out of
this we would have entered something else
for the proportion of factors we could
now simply enter three
then we calculated the communal
activities  get the component
matrix and finally the rotated
component matrix in the component
matrix we could then look at
which factor loaded which variable the
highest and that was then assigned to the
factor here we then found
out that sociable and
sociable the first factor  was assigned to
the third
factor because the greatest values ​​here were hardworking and conscientious because here the greatest values ​​were
presented and warm, cordial and
helpful to the second factor
I hope you liked the video
if you want to read all the content from this
video again is anyone who
would like a  Look at our book
You can find the link in the comments.
Of course I'm happy about a like and we'll
see you next time